Hey Ellie!
Hi Auntie.
What's wrong, Ellie?
Alex and Lyndon have this really cool toy.
Oh, the building blocks, Ellie?
Yeah!
They didn't let you play?
No, they didn't let me play.
Oh, I'm sorry Ellie.
Since you're doing so well in school, you deserve a reward.
Really Auntie?
Thank you!
Alright, I'll be right back.
Ellie, can you clean your room a little bit?
Okay Auntie, I will.
I'm back!
Hi Auntie!
Look what I got you.
Ball pit? Wow, this is so cool, Auntie.
Ellie, this is just half of the toy.
What?
Come on Ellie, follow me.
Wow!
This is so awesome!
You worked so hard in school, you deserve it, Ellie.
Are you ready, Ellie?
Yeah!
Go Ellie!
She looks like she's having so much fun.
Wow! This is fun, Ellie.
I'm having so much fun.
Ellie has all these cool toys?
Yeah.
Hey Alex, Lyndon, come and play.
You want us to play with you?
Really? But we didn't share our toys.
Sharing is caring!
So sharing is caring?
That's a great idea.
We'll be right back!
Okay.
This is an awesome boat.
Sharing is caring!
Thanks for letting us play with you, Ellie.
Yeah and sorry we didn't let you play with us.
Good job, guys.
We learned a valuable lesson.
Sharing is caring.
Bye!